[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه
بعد لقاء الرئيس الفلسطينيه
[تصفيق]
روسيا تعلن الانسحاب اوكرانيا من خط
المواجهه في زفوجيا وبريطانيا تعتبر تزويد
كيف بطائرات حربيه غير مناسبه
تظاهرات واضرابات واسعه في فرنسا تمديدا
بخطه لاصلاح نظام التقاعد
تعزيزات للامن الايراني
اهلا بكم نبدا ونشرتنا من تطورات الزياده
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الى الشرق الاوسط
حيث قال انه واشنطن تعارض اي خطوات تقود
حل الدولتين كتوسيع المستوطنات وهدم
البيوت
مشددانا على ضروره خفضيل
واقبل لقائه مع الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود
عباس في رام الله اكد لينكن ان الرئيس
الامريكي ملتزم بحل الدولتين مشيرا الى ان
واشنطن ترى ان افقا الامل لدى الفلسطينيين
يتقلص ويجب ان يتغير ذلك
بتقديم 50 مليون دولار اضافيه لوكاله
الامم المتحده المعنيه بالفلسطينيين
الاونروا وكذلك العمل على فتح القنصليه
الامريكيه في القدس الشرقيه
بدوره شدد الرئيس الفلسطيني على ضروره وقف
الاجراءات الاسرائيليه احاديه الجانب
والحفاظ على الوضع التاريخي في الاقصى
في غضون ذلك كشفت مصادر للعربيه عن طرح
مصر مبادره لوقف التصعيد الحالي في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه كما سترسل مصر وفدا
امنيا الى تل ابيب لبحث وقف التصعيد ونقل
طلبات السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه بالاضافه
الى رسائل
الفصائل الى الجانب الاسرائيلي
مصادر العربيه افادت ايضا ان مصر طالبه
اسرائيل بضروره وقف التصعيد العسكري دون
اي شروط مسبقه كما ان السلطه الفلسطينيه
تتمسكوا بتجميد اي تعاون مع اسرائيل لحين
الالتزامها بوقف التصعيد العسكري
لمزيد من المتابعه الى من رام الله
الدكتور احمد المجدلاني وهو عضو لجنه
تنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
الدكتور احمد اهلا وسهلا بك هل نجحت
لقاءات بلنكن برايك المكوكيه في وقف
التصعيد فعليا ام لا الامور ما زالت على
حالها من التوتر ولا شيء تغير فعليا
لغايه اللحظه الراهنه لم يحدث اي خطوات
ذات الطبيعه ملموسه
لوقف الاجراءات الاحاديث الجانب والتصعيد
العسكري وايضا التصعيد
الميليشيات الاستعماريه المسلحه
للمستوطنين في الاراضي الفلسطينيه سواء في
القدس في الغربيه كما تتوالى التصريحات
العنصريه التي يطلقها وزراء حكومه
الائتلاف من جيفر وغيره همم
المضاده
للسلطه الفلسطينيه واللي الشعب الفلسطيني
بشكل عام بما في ذلك التصريحات بهدم احياء
في القدس وتهجير المواطنين الفلسطينيين
وبما في ذلك اقرار عقوبه الاعدام بالكرسي
الكهرب
الامريكي الذي سمعناه اليوم
همم هو همم تكرار همم لازاله الخطاب الذي
منذ عامين نسمعه من الادارات الامريكيه
الحاليه وهو خطاب
التعويل الا يمكن التعويل على هذا اللقاء
همم
بينكن والرئيس محمود عباس خصوصا الحديث عن
اعاده فتح القنصليه الامريكيه في القدس
الشرقيه اعاده فتح مكتب منظمه التحرير في
واشنطن الا يمكن التعويل على ذلك
انا اعتقد انه يعني ثقافه توقعاتنا كان
همم يعني همم
دقيق جدا
وكان معروف سقف توقعاتنا وليس عاليه
والل همم تفضل في يعني احنا سمعنا قبل ما
يتسلى من رئيس
ايضا همم ما همته وقال انه احنا سنفتح
السفاره في القدس الشرقيه ونعيد فتح مكتبه
بما في ذلك عدد حوالي سبع التزامات لكن لم
ااه الحقيقه همم لما ينفذ اي واحد منها
ويعني كل مره يعني نشعر ان هذه الالتزامات
تتاكل وتصبح خاليه من اي مضمون لانها لا
يوجد اي خطوه عمليه ملموسه لتنفيذ هذه
الالتزامك كل الاحوال هذه
الزيارها منكم انتم اقرب الى الحدث هل
طلبكم كان باعاده التنسيق الامن مع
اسرائيل فورا
بمعنى انه اي التزام امريكي او اي مبادره
امريكيه مرهونه باعاده التنسيق الامني مع
اسرائيل
يعني خليني اكون واضح وصريح معك انا بدي
اصحح كلمه التنسيق الامريكي هي الترتيبات
الامنيه المشتركه وهي ترتيبات لا لا تقتصر
فقط على التنسيق الامني وانما
ترتيبات تشمل جوانب اخرى همم اهم ما يسمى
التنسيق الامني وبالتالي هذا اولا للتوضيح
الامر الاخر همم قرارنا واضح تماما ما لم
يوقف الاسرائيلي كل الاجراءات الاحاديه
للجانب والتي تمس والتي تجحف اولا
بالقضايا الوضع النهائي للمفاوضات مثل
الاستيطان وتغيير الوضع التاريخي في القدس
والحدود
المياه والموارد الطبيعيه احنا بتقديرنا
هذا الموضوع يعني اليوم يعني بدون ايضا
ضمانات من الجانب الامريكي ولا ومن
الاشقاء العرب الاردن مصر بصراحه احنا مش
شايفين في امكانيه لا استعاده ال ال ال ال
الامور لما كانت عليه قبل الدكتور
مهم بالحديث فقط عن مصر تعرف في مصادر
اكلت منذ قليل العربيه انه القاهره في صدد
اطلاق مبادره وفي وفد مصري امني سيصل الى
تل ابيب وكذلك سيزور رام الله لنقل
الطلبات الفلسطينيه ورسائل الفصائل هل
انتم في جو هذه المبادره
اليوم صباحا نستقبل الرئيس محمود عباس
رئيس الجهاز المخابرات المصريه في كل من
مصر والاردن السيد احمد حسني ايضا
وايضا استمع لهم ااا موقفنا ااا يعرفها
الجانب الاسرائيلي ونقلت من الجانب
الامريكي همم يعني منذ يعني اول امس
ومعروفه يعني لديهم تماما
نتحدث عن عن يعني مطالب نحن نتحدث عن
استحقاقات والتزامات على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه القيام بها وما هي منصوصه
بالاتفاقيات همم
الموقع الحكومه الاسرائيليه همم لديها 36
انتهاك همم
الاتفاقيات الموقع من بينها اربعه قضايا
تمس وتجحف في الوضع النهائي للمفاوضات نعم
من رام الله الدكتور احمد المجدلاني عضو
لجنه تنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور احمد على هذه
المشاركه
قبل ذلك ناقش وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يقف
جالنت مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انتونوبلانكن التحديات التي تواجه اسرائيل
وخاصه ايران
وقالت ان توقيت زياره بلينكن يبعث رساله
واضحه لخصوم اسرائيل مشيرا الى ان اسرائيل
والولايات المتحده متفقتان على ضروره عدم
امتلاك ايران لاسلحه النوويه
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل المتحده ثاني
في ضروره مواجهه ايران وكل من يهدد
السلامه والاستقرار
في غضون ذلك اكد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انتون بلينكن انه بحث مع نظيره الاسرائيلي
كما ذكرنا التزام واشنطن بامن اسرائيل
وتهديدات ايران والوضع في الضفه صارما
نشاط الخامس مستمره فيها ايضا
ارتفاع قتله هجوم مسجد في بيشاور بباكستان
الى مئه شخص
اهلا بكم جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه في تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه قال
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سمعك ان
ارسال الطائرات المقاتله لاوكرانيا امر
غير عملي في هذه اللحظه
هناك ذلك الى ان الطائرات المقاتله
البريطانيه متطوره للغايه ويستغرق الامر
شهورا للتدريب على تشغيلها واكد رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ان بلاده ستواصل مناقشه
ذلك مع حلفائها للتواصل للنهج الصحيح في
الدعم العسكري
هذا وعدنا وزير الدفاع عن النرويجي بورن
اريلد ترامب ان بلاده ستنقل دبابات ليبارد
لاوكرانيا بنهايه مارس القادمه فيما لم
يحدد الوزير النرويجي عددها الا ان بلاده
تملك 66 دبابه من طراز ليقار
وكانت المانيا قد اعلنت انها ستسمح للدول
الاخرى التي تملك هذه الدبابات بنقلها الى
اوكرانيا ايضا
هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني دي
متروكوليبا ان كيف حصلت على تعهدات بتلقي
120 الى 140 دبابه في الموجه الاولى من
هذه الشحنه
هذا ويشكل احتمال تزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات
المقاتله للمساعده في مواجهه روسيا
ميدانيا تهديدا لوحده حلفاء كياف
رغم دعوات المتكرره اطلقتها كيا في
تزويدها المقاتلات افسته عشر الا ان هذا
الامر ليس سهلا وسط مخاوف من التورط
الغربي بشكل اعمق في هذه الحرب
الموقف الامريكي يبدو اكثر تشددا لما كان
عليه فيما يتعلق بتزويد كيف بالدبابات
فحينما سئل الرئيس عن احتماليه تقديم
مقاتلات افس 16 الاكياس كانت الاجابه
بالنفي القاطع
على الجانب الاخر فان موقف فرنسا وبولندا
هو اكثر مرونه فالرئيس الفرنسي من هو
الماكرون قال ان لا شيء مستبعد طالما تعلق
الامر بالمساعده العسكريه لاوكرانيا
لكن ماكرون رهن هذه الخطوه بعوامل عده
ابرزها تجنب التصعيد وتاكيدات بان هذه
المقاتلات لن تلمس التراب الروسي حسب
تعبير
اما بولندا فقال رئيسه وزراء لها ماتيوز
موراوكي انه لا يستبعد ارسال طائرات اف 16
الى اوكرانيا مؤكدا ان اي اجراء من هذا
النوع سيتم بالتنسيق الكامل مع دول النيته
ورغم تعهد امريكيين اوروبي بتزويد كيف
بدبابات المتطوره الا ان هذه الخطوه تحتاج
اشهر لاتمامها ما يدفع كيف للضغط من اجل
مزيد من الدعم استعدادا لمعركه الربيع
والمتوقع ان تكون اكثر شراسه
لمزيد من المتابعه معي منكيا في الام
مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل حذيفه اهلا
وسهلا بك جديد اخبار القصف تحديدا
الصاروقي سواء على كيف او المناطق والمدن
همم المحيطه وهل صحيح ما ذكرته موسكو من
ان القوات الاوكرانيا انسحبت من الخطوط
الدفاعيه لزافالوجيا
تحياتي طالب في الحقيقه القصف في اخر 24
ساعه سجلت اربع ضربات صاروخيه للقوات
الروسيه لم تكن نحو عمق البلاد وانما كانت
في المناطق المتاخمه لخط القتال استهدفت
مواقع لتمركز القوات الروسيه كذلك نفذت
القوات الروسيه الثلاث ضربات جويه واكثر
من 60 ضربه في راجمات الصواريخ انظمه
اطلاق الصواريخ المتعدده همم طبعا فيما
يخص المحور الزبروزه تحديدا تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه ان الروس يحاولون طبعا التقدم
في هذه الاتجاه ولكن همم يحققون الفشل فقط
كما وصف همم يعني هيئه الاركان العامه
المشتركه هذا الهجوم في منطقه
كذلك في محور اخر طبعا
تقول القوات الاوكرانيه ان ال- همم الهجوم
الذي يقوده الروس بالفشل وتكبد الكثير من
الخثائر في هذا المحور عن المحور الاساسي
طبعا الذي تقود فيه القوات الروسيه هجوما
نسطا هو محور باخبط هنا في باخموت في اف
ديفكا في نوف بليف كا كذلك في الايمان هذه
المناطق التي تقود فيها هجوما نشطا في
دانيسك وفي لوغاز اما في صفاته وكوبر
وكريم في هذه المناطق القوات الاوكرانيه
تحقق تقدما بطيئا كما افادت وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه اليوم كان هنالك حوار همم
بودانه وهو رئيس الاستخبارات العسكريه همم
الاوكرانيه والذي افاده طبعا بان القوات
الروسيه سوف يعني تركز في الفتره القادمه
حتى الصيف سوف تركز على استعاده يعني
السيطره الكامله على لغاز هو الهدف
الرئيسي للقوات الروسيه عندما سئل ايضا
امكانيه الهجوم على شبه جزيره القرم من
قبل القوات الاوكرانيه قال لانها هدف
مشروع بالنسبه لنا هذه اراضينا طبعا سوف
نريد كذلك عن امكانيه استخدام الروسي
ردا على اي هجوم على شبه جزيره القرب وقال
ان هذا غير صحيح ولن يحدث مثل هذا الامر
قال كل شيء بدا في 2014 من شبه جزيره
القرب وسوف ننهي هذا كما سماه الاحتلال
طبعا في شبه جزيره الكنز بس بالعوده الى
سؤالي هل صدر اي موقف من اكياف عن تصريحات
موسكو من ان القوات الاوكرانيه انسحبت من
الخطوط الدفاعيه في زابافيا
نعم في الحقيقه لا يوجد اي همم رده فعل
حول هذا الامر لا يوجد تصريح رسمي من قبل
القوات وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه او هيئه
الاركان العامه المشتركه لا يوجد اي بيان
رسمي حتى انباء من هناك يعني تتوارث حول
ان هذا الامر لم يحدث ان القوات ما زال
تحافظ على مواقعها في منطقه الزبرج هذا
هذه الانباء المتوفره حتى الان طالب همم
طيب همم بالنسبه الى موضوع همم الطائرات
يعني بتعرف كيف تريد طائرات اف سته عشر
الى اي مدى يعني موقف الرئيس همم بالامس
كان محبطا لكيف وهل صدر اي موقف من
المسؤولين همم الاوكرانيين حول الموقف
المستجد من الولايات المتحده في مخصوص
موضوع ارسال طائرات
يعني اذا انطلقنا من تصريح مخيل بودلاك
وهو مستشار الرئيس الفاديميرج حول ان كان
في يوم من الايام حصولنا على الدبابات
امرا مستحيلا اقل وقال ااه الجميع كان
يعتقد اننا لن نحصل على الدباباتها اي
الدبابات تتوارث الينا ولدينا جدول معين
لاستلامها وسوف تكون في ارض المعارك قريبا
قال اذا نحن سوف نسعى سوف نجتهد وسوف
والان نقود مفاوضات نشطه جدا حول مساله
التجويد كيف همم الطائرات وقال اننا سوف
نجح في ذلك طبعا هذا جلد الرئيسي لرمشتاين
القادم لاجتماع وزراء الدفاع النيته
اوكرانيا وطبعاصه التي همم تمثل
الاستشاريه الكبرى للجيش الاوكراني هذا
سيكون رئيسي كما فعل وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
دائما شكرا جزيلا لك حذيفه على كل هذه
المتعه
هذا وقال المتحدث باسم سلاح الجو
الاوكراني يوري اجناد في تصريحات صحفيه ان
اوكرانيا بحاجه الى ما يصل الى 200 طائره
متعدده الاغراض للدفاع عن اجوائها واضاف
ان بلاده تسعه الى استبدال الطائرات
السوفيه من انواع مختلفه بنوع واحد من
المقاتلات متعدده الاغراض اف 160
واعتبر ان اوكرانيا هي واحده من اكبر
الدول في اوروبا وتحتاج الى غطاء جوي في
زمن الحرب وفي وقت السلم ايضا
من جانبها حذرت موسكو من تزويد اكياس
بالمقاتلات وقال المتحدث باسم الكرملين
ديمتري بيسكو ان دعوه ليتوانيا لارسال
مقاتلات الى اوكرانيا تؤكد ان دول البلطيق
وفولندا عدائيون
واعتبركوس ان دول البلطيق وفولندا على
استعداد لفعل كل ما يثير المزيد من
المواجهه معروسيا دون التفكير بالعواقب
مشيرا الى ان الدول الاوروبيه لا تضع حدا
لتلك الاستفزازات على حد تعبان
ميدانيا ايضا قال عضو المجلس الرئاسي
للاداره العسكريه والمدنيه لمقاطعه
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تنسحب من خط الدفاع
الاول في المقاطعه
نقلته وكاله سبوتنيك الروسيه للانباء ان
ذا بوروجيت تمثل خطا مواجهه ساخن بين
الجانبين الروسي والاوكراني وهي التي تضم
اكبر محطه نوويه في اوروبا
من جانبها اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
سيطره الجيش على مدينه
شرقيه اوكرانيا وفي بيانها اليوميه قالت
الدفاع الروسيه ان انظمه الدفاع الجويه
الروسيه دمرت خمسه مسيرات واعترضت ثلاثه
صواريخ جراء قصف اوكرانيا
كل هذه المعارك والموجات رائد اهلا وسهلا
بيك جديد شريط الاخبار المدنيه
باقي مناطق الدوم بس ايضا
اخر الانباء رايك
طالب مساء الخير يعني ما زالت ال المنطقه
هنا منطقه دانيت بشكل عام هي الاسخن
بالمعارك التي تشهدها من النواحي الشماليه
والجنوبيه وحتى اطرافها الجنوبيه هي تعتبر
مدينه زاباروجا او مقاطعه زبروجه بالفعل
قال نائب يعني القائم باعمال الرئاسه هنا
همم بان المحورين الاهمين في المقاطعهما
محور طاخمه ومحور اولادار همم قال تحديدا
بان المعارك في اوغلادار باتت يعني ليست
ساخنه كما بداتها الايام الماضيه القوات
الروسيه ذلك لان الجيش الاوكراني يتحسن
جيدا في المدينه وفي اطراف المدينه ولديه
اليات عسكريه ثقيله ولديه مدافع و دبابات
وقال بان الجيش الروسي تعلم دروسا من
معارك ظل نظافه وماريوبل وكذلك باباسنا في
مناطق لوغانس وانه لا داعي للتعجل
بالسيطره على مدينه اوغلودار لديهم خطط
ويريدون ان يحققوا هذه القطط بالتقدم
البطيء وقال بان معارك في اطراف المدينه
الجنوبيه والشرقيه ما بين الطرفين ويرغبون
بالتقدم والسيطره على الاراضي بشكل تدريجي
هذا من جانبه وقال عن باخمط بان الامدادات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه التي همم تصل الى
المقاتلين في مدينه باق متصل عن مدينه
شسافيار طالب التي تقع في الناحيه الغربيه
من باقي
العسكريه الروسيه همم تسيطر على جزء كبير
الان اليوم حتى تحديدا من هذا الطريق
السريع وحتى نهايه هذا اليوم ستكمل
السيطره على الطريق الذي يوصل الامدادات
من مدينه شسافيار الى باخموت في المنطقه
الغربيه ما زالت المعارك مستعره على اطراف
المدينه الشماليه والجنوبيه والشرقيه
وخاصه من الناحيه الجنوبيه تقاتل قوات
فاجنر في مدينه ايفانكا وحرب شوارع بالفعل
ومحاوله للسيطره اكثر على بلدات في المحور
الجنوبي كما انهم يتقدمون ايضا في المحور
الشمالي لكن ليس باتجاه باخم مدينه سيفر
ويسيطرون على بلده بانها منها بلده لو
سمحتي الطالب
بلاجاباتنا التي دارت جد الحولها واليوم
همم اكدت الدفاع الروسيه التي طلبت بعد
الرئيس الروسي بلادي مربوطين بعدم التعجل
باعلان السيطره اليوم الدفاع الروسيه
اعلنت السيطره اعلى
موسكو عم بتقول انا بتكلم عم بيقول انه
القوات الاوكرانيه انسحبت من الخطوط
الدفاعيه الاولى لزابولوجيا ما الذي يعنيه
ذلك والى ماذا هذا دقيق يعني لانه السلطات
الاوكرانيه ما اعترفت بذلك
زاباروج همم
هي همم منطقه صعبه جدا لانها متاخمه
لاوكلادور التي تدور فيها المعارك يعني
خلف جلادار همم همم
زبروا فورا
وهناك تواجد كبير وربما الحديث عن تعزيزات
للقوات الروسيه في ذلك المحور ان كان
اوبلادار او زبرج لان الامدادات متصله ما
بين الخطوط
الممتده من همم من خرصون وصولا الى نهايه
كامل الخط الناري او الخط الساخن الذي
تدور فيه المعارك همم القوات الروسيه بدات
تتقدم ووصلت الى بلده اريحا بلده تاريخ
خضر ما زالت فيها معارك حتى الان تقول بعض
المصادر بان سيطر روسيه تمت على هذه
لكن هناك همم يعني مصادر اخرى تؤكد ان
المعارك ما زالت قائمه في تلك المنطقه همم
روقف نفسه المسؤول في السلطات في زاباروجه
التابعه لروسيا قال بان القوات الاوكرانيه
همم اوصلت امدادات بخط موازي بشكل موازي
ومنها اليات عسكريه ثقيله لاجل اا قصف
وضرب القوات الروسيه التي تتقدم وفي ذات
الوقت قال بان الامدادات وصلت للجيش
الروسي واننا ننتظر معركه
سؤال لانه دائما عم يتردد هذا عم يتردد
هذا الكلام انه منذ نحو اسبوعين والحديث
يدور عن ان مسقط تحضر لهجوم كبير شامل
وحاسم معبد فصل الربيع هل هذا الكلام على
يعني على الارض ما يعززه يعني عند عندما
ترى بامه العين يعني همم هل هنالك مثلا
الحدود غير عاديه همم تعزيزات عددا وعدده
تؤكد ذلك انه لا في هجوم واسع وكبير وشامل
مع بادئ فصل الربيع
ااا ربما تكون هذه
التصريحات من الجانب الغربي من الغرب او
من الجانب الاوكراني طالب لان العمليات
العسكريه الروسيه ااا يعني منتشره وتعمل
في جميع المحاور لن ننتظر حتى الربيع حتى
نرى عمليات نحن نرى في جميع المحاور تقدم
للقوات الروسيه كان في فرداتك او في محور
لوجانس او حتى في محور زاباروجي كمان نرى
بالفعل هناك سيطر على الاراضي بلده
والبلده في مناطق حتى المناطق اسمح لي
طالب لاخر دقيقه هنا المدينه
الجيش الروسي ايضا همم يقاتل في تلك
المناطق وسيطر على ثلثي ماريكا ويتقدم
ينفذ عمليات اقتحام بشكل يومي في ضيفك
والقوات الروسيه هي بدات بالعمليه
العسكريه كبيره لكن التقدم بطيء وهم
يقولون باننا لن نتعجل بالسيطره لاننا
تعلمنا دروس منذ انطلاق العمليه العسكريه
سكتفي بهذا القدر من دونيتس مراس العربيه
رائد الاكبر دائما شكرا جزيلا لك رائد على
كل هذه المتابعه
قال وزير الخارجيه الروسيه سير الى برو ان
نظيره المصري سامح شكري نقل رساله من وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتون بلينكن ما فادوها
ان على القوات الروسيه وقف الحرب ومغادره
الاراضي الاخرانيه
واعتبر لابروف انه لا مبرره من نقل
الاسلحه الثقيله الى اوكرانيا لان ذلك لن
يؤدي الى السلام وفي شان الليبي اكد لبروف
انه اتفق مع شكري على ضروره التنسيق
لاجراء المحادثات الليبيه الليبيه لتسويه
الازمه وفي شان اخر اعرض عن قلقي روسيا من
التصعيد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه مؤكدا
دعمها للاستئناف المفاوضات
بدوره قال شكرا على ظروف تطرقت للاوضاع في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه واهميه التهدئه وعدم
التصعيد
وعلى مستوى العلاقات المشتركه اكد شكري ان
مصر وروسيا تعتزمان زياده حصه العملات
الوطنيه في التسويات الماليه
قال مسؤول باكستانيه بمستشفى في بشاور ان
عدد القتلى جراء التفجير الانتحاري الذي
وقع في مسجد في المدينه ارتفع الى 100 وان
معظم الضحايا هم من رجال الشرطه حيث يقعوا
المسجد المستهدف داخل مجمع يستخدم كمقرا
للشرطه في مدينه بيشاور
وقالت الشرطه ان المهاجمه اجتاز عند
تحواجز تحرسها قوات الامن للوصول الى مجمع
المنطقه الحمراء في ما اعلنت وسائل
الاعلام المحليه ان عمليات الانقاق
لم يكن الضرر الكبير بسبب المتفجره لكن
بسبب موجات الصدمه
كان هناك ثلاثه اشخاص عالقين تحت العوارض
الخرسانيه وعندما انهار السقف سقط على
الارض ما تسبب في اضرار جسيمه
نشاط 5 مستمره فيها ايضا
شركات المانيه تسعى الاستقطاب اصحاب
المواهب من وادي السلكون بعد تسريحيهم
اهلا بكم من جديد بالعوده الى تفجير
الانتحاري في بيشاور لمزيد من المتابعه
ينضم الى الان من اسلام اباد مراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن المزيني عبد الرحمن
اهلا وسهلا بك اخر حصيله لعدد الضحايا
سواء قتل او جرحى وهل هنالك روايه نهائيه
من السلطات الباكستانيه لما حصل
عبد الرحمن يبدو ان عبد الرحمن لم يتوافر
الاتصال به حتى سال انا عوده اليه في سياق
هذه النشره
قال وزير الخارجيه التركيه المولود الشوش
اوغلو انه من غير الممكن حاليا موافقه
تركيا على انضمام السويد لحلف الناتو وفق
ما نقلت وكاله انباء ناظور واشار اوبلو في
الوقت نفسه الى انه بمقدور تركيا الجلوس
والحديث مع السويد في حال اوفى
بالتزاماتها حسب تعبيره وكانت ازمه جديده
قد نشبت بين البلدين اثرا موافقه السلطات
السويديه على حرق نسخه من القران الكريم
امام السفاره التركيه
تشهدوا فرنسا احتجاجات واضرابات واسعه ضد
اصلاحات الاقتراحها الرئيس وعلى راسها رفع
سن التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما
وتامل النقابات ان تكون تظاهرات اليوم
بنفس الزخم الذي شهدته احتجاجات ما سمي
بالخميس الاسود في ال 19 من هذا الشهر
وقد تسببت الاضرابات على مستوى فرنسا في
تعطيل انتاج الكهرباء وتعطيل حركه النقل
العام وايضا المدارس
معنى باريس لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا
الموضوع مراسل العربيه فادي دهوك فادي كيف
الاجواء من عندك والى اي مدى كل هذه
التظاهرات والاحتجاجات ستكون كفيله بتغيير
مشروع الحكومه تحديدا موضوع رفع سن
التقاعد ام لا شيء سيغير من
توجه الحكومه الى رفع سن التقاعد
مساء الخير طالب التظاهرا انطلقت بالفعل
قبل ساعه ونصف من الان ردا على سؤالك
الحكومه صرحت قبل يومين رئيسه الحكومه
اليزابيون قالت انها منفتحه على نقاش بعض
المواد في مشروع القانون من اجل رفع سن
التقاعد لكن مساله رفع سن التقاعد الى 64
عاما ستكون همم ليست قابله قابله لاي نقاش
هذا ما قالته رئيسه الوزراء التظاهرا
انطلقت يوم وكان هناك همم توقعات او همم
هناك اخبار تشير الى انها ستكون مليونيه
هذا الامر من المرجح جدا ان يكون هناك زخم
كبير جدا في الشارع نشهده همم في
التظاهرات راس التظاهره بعيد جدا حتى الان
لان لا مكان لا يوجد لناقف نحن والكاميرا
هناك المتظاهرون يسيرون الان باتجاه منطقه
وهي منطقه تشهد همم عدد كبير من المقر
الحكوميه الحساسه مثل وزاره الدفاع ولكن
ايضا الاسد الحكومه التظاهرات خرجت في
معظم انحاء البلاد هناك تظاهرات انتهت
فعلا في جنوب البلاد على سبيل المثال في
مدينه مارسيليا خرج نحو 200,000 متظاهر
حتى الان في اخر الارقام التي وردتنا
بزياده نحو 60% عن التظاهره السابقه التي
خرجت في التاسعه عشر من هذا الشهر ايضا في
مدينه تولوز خرج نحو 80,000 متظاهر بزياده
قدرت بنحو 30,000 متظاهر عن التظاهره
السابقه تظاهرات اليوم ايضا تتزامن مع
اضراب كما ذكرت في معظم القطاعات في فرنسا
هنا قطاع الطاقه قطاع النقل قطاع التربيه
ايضا هناك تقريبا نصف المعلمين في فرنسا
اعلنوا انهم يشاركون في هذا الاضراب
بالاضافه الى ان هناك ارقام تشير الى ان
نحو 48% من عمال القطاع السكك الحديديه
يقومون بهذا الاضراب وايضا ما بين 70 الى
100% من موظفي شركه توتال الذين يتولون
مساله ضخ النفط من الحقول التابعه لشركه
توتال اعلنت اييه نقابه العمال انهم
مضربون عن العمل وهذا يطفي تخوفات من ان
تشهد فرنسا ازمه في الوقود طبعا هذه
التحركات اليوم هي جاءت بدعوه من ثمان
نقبات للعمران
تعمل جميع الهيئات العماليه مشاركه
بفعاليه في هذه التظاهرات والاحتجاجات
ولكن على مستوى الاحزاب السياسيه الفرنسيه
من هي ابرز الاحزاب المشاركه والداعمه
لهذه التظاهرات والاحتجاجات وهل المساله
مقتصره فقط على موضوع همم رفع سن التقاعد
يعني قال لو تراجعت الحكومه عن هذه
المساله تنتهي الازمه ام لا الامور ابعد
من ذلك بكثير
بشكل رئيسي التظاهرات والاضراب هو احتجاجا
على رفع سن التقاعد لكن ايضا على ارتفاع
الاسعار وترجي الاوضاع المعيشيه في فرنسا
بالنسبه للاحزاب التي تدعم هذه التظاهرات
والاضرابات هناك شقين حقيقه الاول هو ان
هناك الاحزاب اليساريه التي تدعم هذه
التظاهرات وتدعو اليها همم كل الاحزاب
اليساريه التي في فرنسا لكن ايضا هناك
مشاركه من اليمين متطرف على سبيل المثال
ايضا يشاركون في هذه التظاهرات لا يدعون
اليها لكن هناك عدد من انه بيشاركون فيها
قابلت قبل قليل الرجل الاول في الحزب
الاشتراك الفرنسي اوليفيا فور سالته الى
اي مدى انتم ستصمدون امام رفض وتعنت
الحكومه بالتراجع عن رفع سن التقاعد قال
انهم مستعدون للذهاب الى ابعد حد لكي
تتراجع الحكومه وان هذا التحرك لن ينتهي
اليوم هناك تظاهرات واضراب جديد سوف يكون
في السادس من فبراير المقبل
تراب المقبل سوف يستمر لثلاثه ايام وهو
تصعيد جديد سيقوم به ستقوم به ان نقبات
وايضا الاحزاب وهو ايضا سيت همم سيتزامن
مع موعد تقديم مشروع هذا القانون الى مجلس
النواب من اجل ان يتم التصويت عليه
المعارضه اليساريه قدمت حتى الان اكثر من
7000 على هذا على مشروع القانون هذا في
البرلمان من اجل ابطاء حركه تقدمه هناك
هناك حتى يصل
فادي وانت تتابع هذه التظاهرات طيب هي
التظاهرات والاحتجاجات معروف مطلبيه معروف
شو بده ولكن هل الحرب الاوكرانيه ستكون
حاضره بشكل غير مباشر في هذه التظاهرات
لانه سمعنا بعض النقابات او بعض النقابيين
الفرنسيين على شاشات التلفزه الفرنسيه
يعني ينتقدون السياسه الفرنسيه انه انتم
تدعمون اوكرانيا بمليارات الدولارات ونحن
احوج في هذا الوقت الى هذه المليارات لدعم
الاقتصاد الفرنسي الى اي مدى الحرب في
اوكرانيا من هذه الزاويه حاضره في هذه
التظاهرات
الحرف في اوكرانيا حاضره بالدرجه الاولى
بمساله ارتفاع نسب التضخم وارتفاع الاسعار
هم يعتبرون ان الموقف الاوروبي الداعم
لاوكرانيا في الحرب التي تواجهها من قبل
روسيا سببها هذه الازمه سبب زياده في
التضخم وزياده في الاسعار وازمات كبيره
مثل ازمه في الطاقه ايضا بشكل كبير لكن
هناك الشارع مقسوم بين من يعتبر انه همم
الثمن الذي يدفعه الفرنسيون هو جزء بسيط
مما يدفعه الاوكرانيون الاوكرانيون يقولون
انهم يدفعون دما لكن نحن مستعدون للتضحيه
من اجل دعم اوكرانيا
ويقول ان يقولون انه يجب ان يصرف كل هذه
الاموال في فرنسا لان همم الاوضاع في تردد
مستمر وان هناك عدد كبير من الفرنسيين
الذين يحتاجون الى هذه المساعده فادي شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المتابعه نشاهد واياكم
اعزائي المشاهدين هذه التظاهرات الحاشده
من قلب العاصمه الفرنسيه همم باريس كما
ذكر فادي منذ قليل هذه التظاهرات متوقع ان
تكون مليونيه
همم بالطبع يعني التظاهرات النقابيه
مطلبيه ابرز المطالب هو همم ان تعود
الحكومه الفرنسيه عن ما يسمى بقانون اصلاح
نظام التقاعد والقاضي برفع سن التقاعد من
62 عاما الى 64 عاما اضافه الى همم بعض
الامور المطلبيه الاخرى اذا هذه المشاهد
مباشره من العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس لهذه
التظاهرات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الحال لم يكن افضل في بريطانيا حيث ينظم
المعلمين في جميع انحاء بريطانيا اضرابا
غدا بعد عقد من الارباح الضيئيله في نظام
مدرسي تموله الدوله
بالكامل من قبل الحكومه حيث قام العديد من
المعلمين بشغل وظائف ثانيه او ترك مهنه
التعليم تماما
كما سيخرج مئات الالاف من العمال في هذه
التظاهرات بما فيهم موظفوا السكك الحديد
وموظفه الخدمه المدنيه ما يجعله اكبر يوم
تظاهر في بريطانيا
اذا كان بامكاني جاني وما يكفي من المال
وعدم الاضطرار الى القيام بالدروس
الخصوصيه في المساء
فلاحياه اكثر سعاده الراتب لا يشد الحاجه
حتى الاخر من الشهر والتوتر الذي يسببه لا
يصدق على الاطلاق هناك مره افكر من اين
سياتي المال كل شهر بمثابه
انهم محرومون من حقوقهم لقد سائم من
الطريقه التي تسير بها الامور
مازلنا في لندن حيث كلف خروج بريطانيا من
الاتحاد الاوروبي الاقتصاد البريطاني
124 مليار دولار سنويا كاستثمارات لم تحصل
عليها حسب ما افادت وكاله بلومبرج
ووفقا لبيانات الوكاله فان حجما الناتج
المحلي الاجماليه البريطانيه عامه 20 22
كان ليرتفع بنسبه 4% لو لم تغادر لندن
الاتحاد الاوروبي كما خسرت بريطانيا نحو
370,000عامل من دول الاتحاد
ذكر بيانو لوزاره التجاره الامريكيه ان
الولايات المتحده اضافه سبعه كيانات
الايرانيه الى قائمه الحظر التجاري
الامريكي بسبب المساهمه تلك الكيانات في
الجهود العسكريه الروسيه عن طريق المساعده
في انتاج الطائرات
التقى وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي كوهين
وزير الخارجيه اليونانيين الذي يزور
اسرائيل حيث ناقشه سلسله من القضايا
الثنائيه والاقليميه اهمها التهديد
الايراني واهميه اعلان الحرس الثوري منظمه
الارهابيه في اوروبا
ويعتبروا هذا الاجتماع
وكوهين بحسب وزاره الخارجيه
في ايران ومع تراجع ملحوظ في الاحتجاجات
بعد حملات قمع قوات الامن يبدو ان الامر
ليس كذلك في زهدان عاصمه مقاطعه السيستاني
بلوشيستان حيث تتاهب المدينه للانفجار في
اي وقت بعد ان اعتقلت السلطات رجل الدين
عبد المجيد مراد زهيد وهو احد المقربين من
مولوي عبد الحميد خطيب مسجد زهدان واحد
المؤيدين للاحتجاجات وذلك في محافظه
سيستان البستان على خلفيه الاحتجاجات
الجاريه في البلاد على ما ذكرت وكاله
الانباء الايرانيه ارنا
ونقلت وكاله ايرنا عن مصدر المطلع قوله ان
امراه اوقفته الاجهزه الامنيه بمدينه
زهدان بسبب اتهامات تتعلق بتظليل الراي
العام وارتباطه بالعديد من الافراد ووسائل
الاعلام الاجنبيه
وسائل الاعلام الايرانيه معارضه قالت ان
المدينه تشهد تكفيفا من تواجد قوات الامن
لمواجهه رد فعل السكان من ملاحقه
المحتاجين ورجال الدين
وتشهد المدينه منذ سبتمبر الماضي اعمال
عنف واسع بين المحتاجين والقوات الامن حيث
قتل فيها العشرات فيما اقالت السلطات
اثنين من كبار المسؤولين الامنيين في
المنطقه بينهم قائد شرطه زهدان بعد نشر
تحقيق رسمي افاد بوجود اهمال من قبل بعض
الضباط ادى الى مقتلي مدني
عبرت الصين عن التقارير التي تفيد بان
الولايات المتحده تدرس وقف الموافقات على
اي تراخيصه لتصدير السلع وخدمات لشركه
الاتصالات السلكيه ولا سلكيه الصينيه
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
الاجراء الذي اتخذته الولايات المتحده
ووصفته بالهيمنه التكنولوجيا
هذه التقارير ونتابع تلك التطورات
المتحده مفهوم الامن القومي
لقمع شركات الصينيه بصوره غير مقبوله مثل
هذه الممارسات تتعارض مع مبادئ اقتصاد
السوء والقواعد الاقتصاديه والتجاريه
الدوليه
في بيئه الاعمال
تكنولوجيا صارخه ستواصل الدفاع بحزم عن
الحقوق والمصلح المشروعه للشركات الصينيه
ان الولايات المتحده ملتزمه باستخدام
الاسلحه التقليديه والنوويه للرابع
والادفاع عن كوريا الجنوبيه فضلا عن قيام
واشنطن وسلبيات لتعزيز الردع ضد التهديدات
النوويه
[موسيقى]
والولايات المتحده للدفاع عن كوريا
الجنوبيه من انشطه كوريا الشماليه
المتعدده هذا ما اعلن عنه وزير الدفاع
الامريكي الذي يزور الصور للمره الثالثه
بصفته وزيرا للدفاع
التزامنا بحمايه جمهوريه كوريا لا يزال
ثابتا كما تلتزم الولايات المتحده من
راسخا بالردع المواسع الذي يتضمن استخدام
مجموعه كامله من الوسائل العسكريه
الامريكيه بمفي ذلك الاسلحه التقليديه
والنوويه وكذلك الدفاع الصاروخي
الوزير الامريكي في مؤتمر المشترك مع
نظيره الكوري الجنوبي اشار الى ان كوريا
الشماليه ارتكبت عام 2022 عدا غير مسبوق
من الاستفزازات موضحا ان امريكا وكوريا
الجنوبيه
التي استقرار الوضع في المنطقه ومؤكدا ان
التدريبات العسكريه المقبله بين البلدين
تهدفه لضمان ان يقابل الحلفاء التهديدات
النوويه الكوريه الشماليه
وهو ما تحدث عنه وزير الدفاع كوريا
الجنوبيه كذلك
مؤكدامهما بالتعزيز التعاون الثلاثي مع
اليابان ايضا
حقيبه اللقاء كشف بيان المشترك لبنتغون عن
اتفاق بتوسيع نطاق التدريبات المشتركه بين
البلدين هذا العامه
لوزير الدفاع الامريكي بعنوان التحالف
ويقف على اهبه الاستعداد قال فيه ان
واشنطن وصول ستجريان منورات تحاكي
سيناريوهات معقده تركز على التهديدات
النوويه في شبه جزيره الكوريه ملوك الشيخ
العربيه
[موسيقى]
شكرا جزيلا طالب اخبار الرياضه حياكم الله
يفتتح الاهلي المصري كاس العالم للانديه
في المغرب وهو يستهدف تحقيق ميداليه
الجديده في البطوله التي يشارك فيها للمره
الثالثه على التوالي والثامنه في تاريخه
بطل افريقيا
انا على الفريق اذ كان بوابته للحصول على
الميدان البرونزيه في 2006 نجح الاهلي في
تحقيق المركز الثالث في اخر نسخه من
البطوله
في اليوم الاخير لنافذه انتقالات اللاعبين
الشتويه وافق نادي تشيلسي على انتقاله
لاعبي خطي وسط الفريق جورجيني والى ارسنال
في صفقه قدرت ب 12 مليون جنيه
سيخضع اللاعب الايطالي لفحص طبي ويوقع
عقدا لمده عام ونصف وشارك اللاعب في 25
مباراه هذا الموسم وتمكن من تسجيل ثلاثه
اهداف
وعلينا بايرن ميونخ عن ضمن الظهير
البرتغالي من مانشستر سيتي على سبيل
الاعاره مع امكانيه ضمه بشكل نهائي في
الصيف كانسل له اكتفى بثلاثه مشاركات في
تشكيله الاساسيه في عشر مباريات منذ
انتهاء كاس العالم اعطيك وفقد مكانه لصالح
نثناك بعد خلاف مع المدرب
ميلان في اخر مباراهتين له في الدوري
الايطالي امام الاسيا وساسولو سجل رقم
قياسيا سلبيا يظهر التراجع في اداء الحالي
فشل ميلان في استعاده توازنه في الدوري
الايطالي ووصل لانهيار عقب السقوط بفضيحه
امام فريق ساسولو بخمسه اهداف الاثنين بعد
اسبوع من الخساره امام لاتسيو برباعيه
نظيفه ارقام سلبيه لحقته بعد تلقيه هزيمه
باربعه اهداف او اكثر ولاول مره في تاريخه
بمبارتين متتاليتين بالدوري الايطالي
ودونت تلقيه لخمسه اهداف على ارضه لاول
مره ايضا منذ عام 1977
ميلان لم يحقق طموحات جماهيره ولم يواكب
ما حققه الموسم الماضي بتتويج بلقب الدوري
الايطالي في رصيده احد عشر انتصارا وخمسه
تعادلات 45 هائم احتل بها المركز الخامس
في جدول الترتيب وبفارق 15 نقطه عن
المتصدر نابولي لتقلص حظوظه في الحفاظ على
اللقب كما خرج من دوري 16 من بوابه تورينو
وخسر كاس السوبر الايطالي لصالح غريره
انتر ميلان في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
قبل اسبوعين
لاعبوني لان فشلوا تحت قياده المدرب بيولي
في تحقيق الفوز في اخر خمس مباريات بمختلف
البطولات حيث تلقى الفريق ثلاث هزائم
وتعادل في مبارتين وينتظره ديربي جديد
امام جاره انتر في الجوله الحاديه
والعشرين الاحد المقبل فيما يبدو ان مصير
بيولي سيكون معلقا بنتائج الفريق في دوري
الابطال وتحديدا عندما يواجه توتنهام
الانجليزيه الشهر المقبل في دور 16 من
المسابقه القريه
[موسيقى]
فاز
الهولنديين بالمركز الاول في المرحله
الاولى من طواف السعوديه للدراجات
الهوائيه في العلا وتسابقوا فريقي وريكا
على الصوربيدو سامي رجوفيتش من فريق
البحرين توريوس والالماني ماكس من فريق
الكوميديس في المرحله التي انطلقت من مطار
العلا وانتهت في خيبر بمسافه نحو 180 كم
ليعتلي صداره التصنيف العام قبل انطلاق
المرحله الثانيه
اليوم في المرحله الاولى في 32
اليوم والدعم اللي نحظه فيه هو اللي
يمكننا من صرافه مثل هذه الفعاليات
ويمكننا كذلك من اظهار للعالم بعض المناطق
الجميله من المملكه
وشاهدنا امس الدرعيه وكانت يونسكو سايت
واليوم العلا نظره المنتخب
ومتمكنه للمشاركه باذن الله في طوافات
عالميه وايضا همم بطولات ان شاء الله
اسيويه ودوريه ان شاء الله يوصف
ان شاء الله نسوي اللي علينا والباقي على
الله
ان شاء الله نقدم افضل الازاي مثل الوطني
مثلنا
هذه كانت ابرز اخبار الرياضه
[موسيقى]
شكرا لك يا محمد مصائب قوم ان عند قوم
فوائد في الوقت الذي يتم فيه تصريحه عشرات
الالاف من الموظفين في وادي السلكون
بولايه كاليفورنيا تجد شركات المانيه
في ظل ما تواجهه من شحن في سوق العمل
ونقصا في العماله من ذوي المهارات
الاساسيه خصوصا في هندسه البرمجيه وقد
قالت مجموعه بدكم وهي جمعيه رقميه في
المانيا تضم اكثر من الفيش الشركه في
الاقتصاد رقمي قالت ان لدى المانيا
237,000 وظيفه شاغره في مجال التكنولوجيا
المعلومه
وتعمل الحكومه الالمانيه على تبسيط قواعد
الهجره
وتروج الاحتمال الحصول على الجنسيه
الالمانيه بسهوله
لاغراء المهاجرين المحرار
نشاط الخامسه المفصله وفينكم بها من قناه
العربيه والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]